une ville d'ordinaire grouillant et
joyeuse aujourd'hui au ralenti et sur la
défensive fini la fête à odessa chaque
entreprise travaille à la résistance
face à un éventuel assaut russe dans les
sous sols de cet immeuble direction un
atelier de couture qui fournit en temps
ordinaire un site internet de mode
branché
mais on s'est converti en fait des sous
vêtements chauds pour nos soldats allez
les filles on s'y met valentina chapelle
et ses couturières ont décidé de rester
à odessa pour se battre à leur façon
avec la nostalgie du temps d'avant la
guerre
mon seul écho avant dans ces temps
heureux ont confectionné ces jolies
robes de soirées avec des paillettes
pour aller faire la fête on voulait être
belle bien m'habiller même journée on
fabrique des gilets pare-balles
péter votre notaire qui choquait
ça ne nous enchante pas bien sûr on
préfère confectionner de belles blues
oui mais il faut le faire
avant le déclenchement de la guerre dans
ce restaurant c'était soirée foot bière
et hamburgers victor titoff le chef
cuisinier se concentre aujourd'hui
exclusivement sur le ravitaillement des
soldats qui craignent la retraite vous
avez les salades c'est bon oui
il y avait plein de table l'ambiance
était vraiment bonne et regardez
maintenant ce n'est plus un restaurant
c'est un stock alimentaire pour les
soldats
c'est très dur on était heureux et on se
retrouve là comme
dans les cuisines des employés qui
depuis presque deux semaines travaillent
gratuitement
l'heure est à l'effort collectif
l'heure n'est pas au profil ni aux
bénéfices on veut travailler à la fin de
cette guerre même les écoles fermées
sont transformés en bases arrières plus
d'élèves mais des drapeaux aux prêts à
servir dans les couloirs les enfants
bien sage sur les photos et les pots de
crayon bien taillée ont laissé la place
aux soldats et aux équipements
militaires un gamin pour vous avez des
périscopes c'est bon les opérateurs
la cheffe s'est-elle natacha dynamique
guide touristique dans sa vie d'avant
habitué à organiser la vie de groupe
de punk à castillon vous voyez il y a un
enfant qui a laissé son doudou il se
retrouve maintenant à côté d'une
casquette deux soldats on espère bien
que cette peluche retrouvera son
propriétaire bientôt quand les enfants
reviendront
les forces russes sont actuellement à
130km d'odessa dans la ville de nicolet
if qui leur résistent actuellement
odessa s'est barricadé au défunt est
prête à un assaut assauts maritime
assaut terrestre c'est la question que
se posent les habitants de ce port
stratégique sur la mer noire